time has done little to heal the wounds
the earthquakes that devastated War
ravaged towns and cities in Syria have
robbed its people of what little they
had left
the challenges ahead involve rebuilding
what was destroyed hundreds of thousands
of people have been made homeless in
both government and rebel-held
territories while worsening the
displacement crisis in the
opposition-controlled Northwest Enclave
with so many homes destroyed people have
lived with no choice but to live in
terms however the area is already
overcrowled with more than 2 million
people living in difficult conditions
the needs are great in a region where
four million people were dependent on
Aid before the natural disaster but Aid
agencies say help has been slow and
inadequate they blame this partly on the
lack of funding without which the
ability to respond will be limited we
cannot escape to the level of needs
mostly because we lack funding and
because
also the coordination structures that
were responding to Northwest Syria
before are based in Turkey and most of
them have been also affected by the
earthquake Syria was already among the
most underfunded humanitarian crises in
the world and so far less than half of
the 400 million dollars requested by the
UN to deal with the immediate needs from
the disaster has been funded but it's
not the only problem
a coordinated effort is needed in a
largely isolated region which lacks the
capacity and resources to face its
latest catastrophe
all the while access to Northwest Syria
depends on a political decision by the
Syrian government biggest thing is
predictable access we saw the addition
of two border crossings for una to
access was a good start but at the
three-month window that you know they're
operating off of is wholly insufficient
to scale the humanitarian response into
Northwest Syria furthermore is the
second piece which is that we need a
principle not a political response an
unconscionable failure is how some Aid
workers describe the international
response in Syria so far for those who
survived the recovery from the aftermath
of This Disaster has yet to start